let's go next to Mo from West Virginia
Mo from West Virginia welcome what's on
your mind today sir
hi David
um I just wanted to ask you um it might
be a two-part question sure uh one is
that I I see on mostly left-wing media
uh corporate media does this too where
they say that Trump and DeSantis are too
far to the right
when it comes to policies and positions
to gain traction with Independence
they're turning off Independence well as
we all have seen in the past before
the primaries come first so obviously
they're going to go for the right
Wingers to win their primaries yes after
the primaries there's a lot of shift in
their policies and positions to gain
back some momentum with Independence do
you see like
uh anyone in the media actually like
paying attention to that is that a thing
that could happen with DeSantis or Trump
I think it'll happen to a degree with
both of them if they win the primary but
we'll all realize it's not genuine and
also I think right now the environment
is such that they all know they need to
play to this extreme Maga right that
remember doesn't really even care about
policy they care about culture issues
fighting wokeness owning the libs and
some very vague you know I'll build a
wall or whatever
um I actually think there's more risk
right now to the Republican candidate of
playing to the middle in the general
that they will they will turn off some
of those extreme voters so I think to
some degree whoever wins the Republican
primary will make a slight play to the
middle I think it won't be as much as we
often see because it's really risky and
I think it will be transparently
disingenuous
where's the risk though because once
they win the primary they're that you're
Republican guy so they've got the risks
you have to remember right now Maga is
made up of the traditional Republican
electorate
plus people who only ever started
following politics because of trump many
of those people if they become
disaffected with whoever it is Trump
DeSantis whatever they will stay home
and then it'll really hurt your ability
to win that's the risk that they will
just say this wasn't what I thought I
was getting I'm staying home screw them
they are willing to do that because they
are not traditional historical voters
that vote every election and so those
folks are much more open to simply not
voting at all
I guess that's true but that's mostly I
see that as a bigger risk but DeSantis
than Trump because Trump trump has that
voter base like I feel like even
DeSantis voters if Trump becomes the
winner of the primary they'll still vote
for Trump just because he's the
Republican they're not going to vote
Democrat in any situation
votes you're right they mostly will but
this is a very unusual situation where
at this point Trump pretending to Pander
to the middle a little bit is not going
to really win him any votes because
it'll be so obviously disingenuous and
it has the risk of turning off some of
his supporters I think the most likely
outcome is Trump just doesn't do it and
he doesn't play to the middle at all
Trump doesn't
yes that's my guess okay that's my
prediction
do you see any specific policies that
you think he would be more likely to
flip on or positions he takes right now
that he would be willing to give up I
really don't and remember he barely
takes any policy positions I mean he's
running a social issues anti-woke I won
in 2020 they treated me unfairly Biden's
a Marxist type of campaign it's already
pretty devoid of policy so there's not
that much policy he even could flip on
right there's no nothing like he doesn't
give out specifics like I mean I guess
he said he would build he was going to
build tent cities and force homeless
people in there right and maybe he'll
cancel that plan I don't know
right but like his position on Ukraine
where he was asked in the town hall like
would you stop supporting Ukraine who do
you want to win the war he's he's not
taking a side he kind of just made an
appeal to emotion saying he just wanted
people to stop dying exactly right
do you see him leaning one way or
another more
just I'm really not sure you know it's
it's it's it's it's just a it's a Fool's
errand to try to predict exactly Which
Way Trump will lean on these issues
it'll be whatever he thinks will benefit
him at the time based on what's being
said on Fox News and what people around
him are saying it's it's not even worth
taking a guess I just have no idea
so you'll think he'll stick to whatever
people around him are saying more yeah
even if they're not like they're really
his like advisors on helping him win the
election per se that's what he said
historically
okay yeah
all right my friend uh I appreciate Mo
from West Virginia great to hear from
you let's take a very quick break and
then we'll take more calls so hang on if
you're waiting to talk to me one of our
sponsors today is Bon charge I have
always enjoyed dry saunas you get in
there your heart rate is up dilates the
blood vessels can soothe achy joints and
muscles it's relaxing it's just a great
way to remove a little stress Bond
charge is the creator of the infrared
sauna blanket which you can enjoy from
home super easy to set up heats up fast
you don't have to have your head inside
like at a traditional sauna at the gym
nice for meditating or reading getting
work done relaxing I have found it to be
a great way to unwind at the end of a
long day easy to clean Sleek lightweight
design easy to store and comes with a
12-month warranty and of course if you
don't love it returns are super easy but
I think you will love it and you'll get
15 off when you go to boncharge.com
Pacman and use the code Pacman the link
is down below